i want to talk about how to avoid some
common mistakes when you're writing a
historical paper this could apply to
a term paper
to a blue book essay even really to your
master's thesis if you wanted to i want
to talk about three phrases that you
might be tempted to use in a historical
essay that actually muddy what you're
trying to say and undercut your point
more than it helps
so these three phrases that i want to
talk about are
throughout history
it was inevitable
and
and that's why
insert country here
is so great today
so why are these phrases so problematic
let's start with throughout history so
this is something that you frequently
see in writing uh
from
historical essays to pieces of
journalism and it often has the ring of
making something seem
really
strong and
adding the weight of eons of history
behind a single sentence history is a
very long thing i mean for recorded
history we're going back maybe five
thousand seven thousand years and think
about the many different cultures and
types of people and ideas that existed
throughout that time period if you're
sitting down to write an essay about say
the cold war and you start throughout
history people have feared nuclear
attack well the first thing your reader
is going to think is wait the nuclear
bomb was only developed in 1945 i mean
that's not throughout history that's
only throughout the last 70 years or
what about throughout history people
have gone to war over religion your
reader might think
well what about when people didn't live
close enough to each other to go to war
about different beliefs and do we really
want to send the message that having
different religions means that you
necessarily have to go to war one thing
that throughout history does is it makes
an assumption about human nature right
um that
the way that people think now
is the way that people have always
thought throughout history or the way
that people behave now is the way that
people have always behaved throughout
history and if there's anything that is
one of the core beliefs of the study of
history it's that people are different
over time it's fun to study the past
because people in the past weren't like
us they had different ideas different
beliefs different cultural values and so
if you want to be really strong about
how you start a historical essay always
start it in a really specific part of
time that you're talking about so if
you're talking about the period from
1945 to 1965
say in the post-war era
or
in the late 19th century
and you might also add
in the united states
right this shows that you have a strong
grasp of both the time and the place
that you're writing about and so you can
make an argument that is specific to
that time period okay let's move on to
it was inevitable i think we like to use
the word inevitable because it's long
and it sounds pretty cool
but think about what inevitable really
means it means
it was unavoidable there was no other
thing that could have happened now think
of a version of history where everything
is inevitable everything was just going
to happen no matter whether anyone did
anything or not that shows an
interpretation of history that says that
people's choices don't matter
and if you want to emphasize anything in
history it's how much choices matter
there are very few things that are
inevitable in history most of them i
would say are natural disasters right
that there is going to eventually be an
earthquake in california is inevitable
because there's a fault line that's
something that humans can't control but
for almost everything else in history
humans can control it and they do decide
how to react to certain situations for
example take the sinking of the uss
maine in havana harbor right this is the
event that leads to the united states
going to war with spain over cuba in
1898 and the reason that this happened
was because the uss maine exploded in
havana harbor now we know
and the spanish suggested at the time
that the reason that the uss maine
exploded was due to a spontaneous
combustion on board there was an
equipment malfunction the united states
chose to believe
that the ship sinking was the result of
a spanish bomb and declared war now you
might have said war was inevitable but
it really wasn't there were many ways
that the united states could have chosen
differently in that moment to say
well maybe we will believe the spanish
and just leave it alone or maybe we'll
send some financial aid to cuba but we
don't have to go to war
when you get rid of inevitability in
history you open up new choices
new ways that things could have gone
and that is really the heart of history
is the possibility for things to be
different than they were and different
than they are
okay let's finish up with and that's why
insert country here is so great today
you see this all the time in historical
papers and i think writers are very
tempted to finish a historical essay
with some expression of patriotism and
maybe in a few rare cases this is true
you could say
the united states is a better place
today than it was in the 1950s thanks to
the civil rights act of 1964 but it's
something you want to use very sparingly
because usually the scope of a
historical paper and think about our or
throughout history here
isn't so huge as to merit the reaction
to it being this is the heart of what
makes america great today i've read
historical papers about the spanish flu
in 1919 that end with and that's why
america is great today ask yourself is
this relevant and even if it is is it
the most relevant way that you could end
an essay for a historical essay you want
to keep your conclusions very specific
the same way that you want to keep your
period of time specific so if you're
talking about the post-war era
conclude with something that you can
actually substantiate that you have
substantiated in your essay about the
post-war era
say the wealth generated by
industrialization after world war ii
was the reason that the baby boom
happened don't say and that's why
america is great today what do you mean
by great
do you mean
economically great
culturally great politically great
it's a little too vague and vagueness
can really undermine your argument as
opposed to supporting it in a way these
are all kind of
appeals for
human nature appeals
for
the natural progress of history
and appeals to patriotism
that are less rooted in the facts of
what you want to say
then they are rooted in ways of trying
to get your readers sympathy instead
what you can do is be specific
in your time and your place
emphasize
choices and points where things might
have gone differently than they did
and end with a conclusion that is very
related to the things that you
specifically addressed remember you
never want to introduce new information
in your conclusion and saying and that's
why america is great today
is new information because it might not
necessarily be related
instead think about what it was you
proved in this paper and key your
conclusion directly to that